i never thought i would agree with aoc
i never thought i really never thought i
would agree with aoc
on something like the george floyd case
the trial of derrick chauvin
for the not not just the killing of
george floyd the murder of george floyd
and yet aoc and i agree on a very narrow
point
we agree that the verdict that the jury
reached
was unjust so no
this verdict is not justice
frankly i don't even think we call it
full accountability
because there are
multiple officers that were there
it wasn't just just derek chauvin
and i also don't want this moment to be
framed as this system working
working because it's not working
and
that's what creates a lot of complexity
in this moment
that's what creates a lot of complexity
what's the complexity the verdict is
just or it's unjust
i think it's unjust aoc seems to think
it's unjust
so good we'll get rid of it on appeal
right maybe i don't think that's exactly
what she's saying on this narrow point
though aoc is right
for all the wrong reasons i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from top 10 guy one
who says the judge looked at the latest
cnn ratings and naturally assumed that
nobody on the jury has been watching the
news that's a very good point actually
that's an astute observation the judge
famously in this case said look what
maxine waters said
maybe that should cause this to result
in a mistrial
the threats that people are seeing from
not just the radicals on the left
not just the street people but but even
from the elected officials the
pressure from joe biden but what what
the judge said was
i trust that the jury is following
instructions
and not listening to the news well
you're right cnn ratings are the only
evidence for that claim but i think
the overwhelming evidence is of course
the jury knew
what this trial meant blm burned the
country down last year over this
so even if they weren't reading the new
york times every day during the trial
they knew exactly
what was going on you heard aoc
mention this distinction between justice
and accountability and you're going to
hear the left
make this distinction a lot over the
next few days it's kind of like this
distinction that they're making between
equality and equity
and on the one hand these distinctions
are meaningless they're distinctions
without a difference
but i i do think actually that there is
some
worthwhile distinction here between
accountability and justice usually
usually what the left does when they
coin new terms like this
or when they put a lot of emphasis on
one term over another
is they say look obviously this isn't
justice this was mob rule here
the total overwhelming of the judicial
system the guy was convicted in the
media not in
a court of law however
we need to still say that it's sort of
like just so we're just going to make a
new term
equality we're going to make a new term
equity and we like equity and we hate
equality well here what's the difference
between accountability and justice
i think the subtle difference here is
that justice
refers to an eternal
objective concept right justice refers
to
the moral law which is eternally true
whatever we all think here on earth even
if we act very unjustly
like the sort of injustice we saw
yesterday in the derrick chauvin trial
accountability is a little different
accountability is like
responsiveness to people
so when when you're talking about
there's no accountability i think
it very subtly plays into this radical
subjectivism
that you're seeing from the left and
especially from people like aoc on the
left
which is that look there are no eternal
standards we're going to remake the
whole system
we're going to upend the entire moral
order
we're going to flip society inside out
and the only standard that will matter
is what we think we the people who make
the standards
you you will not have to worry about
justice and
account of accountability to god you
just you'll just worry about
accountability meaning you know
responsiveness
to me to us we
the radical leftists who are going to
remake the world by redefining all the
terms
that i it's a it's a subtle distinction
but i do think that's what is at play
here
that the left is ultimately interested
this is why they don't want to say that
justice was served here
in the case of derek chovin is because
what they're ultimately interested in
is not reforming the police system or
reforming the justice system a little
bit
that is completely disingenuous when
they say that they want to undo the
whole thing they're saying the entire
country is rotten to the core and it
won't be set right until
they are in power and they get to remake
everything and even then it's going to
be a perpetual revolution
this is what the left always does it's
why fidel castro was wearing his
military fatigues until he was 92 years
old
because the revolution is still going on
it doesn't matter that castro held power
for 60 years
no there's still more work to do viva
siempre la revolucion
that i think is what is at play here
it's why it's so important to pay
very close attention to these little
words is
when you accept the left's new language
you accept whole premises here
this is very much the subject of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now
for pre-order who knows how much longer
it will be available for pre-order so
the jury comes out
and in a deeply unjust
decision reads their verdict derrick
chauvin
guilty is charged members of the jury i
will now read the verdicts as they will
appear in the permanent records of the
fourth judicial district
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court fourth judicial district
state of minnesota plaintiff
versus derrick michael chauvin defendant
verdict
count one court file number 27 cr2012646
we the jury in the above entitled matter
as to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 44 pm signed juror 4 person
juror number 19.
same caption verdict count 2. either
during the above entitled matter as to
count two
third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury
person juror number 19
same caption verdict count three we the
jury in the above entitled matter has to
count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april 2021
at 1 45 pm jury 4 person019
there it is derek chauvin staying
basically perfectly stoic as this is
being read out
they're accusing him not or convicting
him i suppose
not just of negligence not just of
manslaughter
but of murder the intentional killing
of george floyd what was the evidence
for that
here's the evidence that i think
impelled the jury to reach this
guilty verdict on all counts maxine
waters says there's going to be riots
i think that was very important evidence
the president of the united states but
so many other people kamala harris
bailing the roc the george floyd rioters
out of
out of jail last year blm torching the
whole country
threats to the livelihoods and lives of
the jurors
families and to themselves i'm not even
saying explicit threats i'm saying the
implicit threat
of a mobster who walks in and says gosh
nice place she got here sure would be a
shame if something happened to it
and that threat had credibility because
blm got away with burning the country
down
last year along with antifa i think
that's the evidence that led
to the guilty verdict because the
evidence presented in court
weakened the prosecution's case the
evidence presented in court remember
the whole argument that the media made
about george floyd's death
is that derek chovin intentionally put
the knee on the neck
and blocked his airway and that's what
that's why he died and there was nothing
else then we find out later on
actually he had three times the lethal
dosage of fentanyl in his system
actually derek shivan didn't pull him
out of that car and drag him to the
ground to murder him
george floyd asked to be taken out of
the car
actually the claim george floyd when he
said i can't breathe he was saying that
before chauvin basically even had his
hands on him
more and more and more and more and more
evidence even the next thing
later on the prosecution changed its
case the argument initially was
chauvin had the knee on george floyd's
neck then it became he had the knee on
his neck area what's the neck area
oh i don't know your back your shoulders
it didn't even have the neckline right
so if we're just looking at new evidence
presented in court
at the very most this guy would have
gotten manslaughter maybe he would have
gotten off completely
but that wasn't the evidence here that's
why it's an unjust verdict
even regardless of whether or not
derrick chauvin
committed the manslaughter it's an
unjust verdict because the whole system
was upended we
we heard the judge say this yesterday
except this cowardly judge didn't want
to actually
follow his his argument to its logical
conclusion
when he said yeah maxine waters coming
out and threatening everybody
and inciting riots if they don't get the
verdict that they want that might result
in
in the declaration of a mistrial on on
appeal that might create problems on
appeal but here
right now i don't want to do that i'm
not going to do that
that is deeply unjust it should that is
as aoc
would say though for all the different
reasons one of the
arguments that the justice system is not
working
moreover though i feel bad for derrick
chauvin
i do you're not allowed to say that but
i do i feel bad for derek showing
because this isn't about him
none of this trial is about him none of
the trial is about what happened between
him and george floyd
none of the facts matter to the verdict
in that trial
here's here's what matters saint
george saint george floyd
died as a martyr he was persecuted
for his skin color by a racist
bigoted probably member of the ku klux
klan named derek chauvin
and he was murdered and chovin planned
this out you know and he just couldn't
wait to murder him because he hates
black people
and then finally the people woke up
people of all good faith in america they
woke up in a creed occur and they
demanded justice and they peacefully
protested
there was a little fire there's some
building but it was mostly
fiery but mostly peaceful protests and
now
we have defeated this eve this perfect
ultimate evil
in derek chauvin of course the evil of
racism remains but this is a great
victory
derek chauvin is going to go to prison
right now
because of that narrative whether or not
derek shoving did anything wrong
i'm really not coming in one way or the
other on whether or not he did anything
wrong here
on even on the manslaughter charge i'm
just saying that's completely separate
from why derek chovin is going to prison
this this is what's going on in this
country right now
the justice system is disconnected from
a sense of justice
it's not for the reason aoc says though
aoc i don't think has any real sense of
justice whatsoever
i think the way that we can get back to
a proper justice system is if we realize
what the justice system
is for you got to know what things are
for like for instance is that gadget on
your counter is that a confection oven
or is that gadget on your counter a
toaster or is that gadget on your
counter an air fryer well you know what
with the power air fryer it can be all
three
you have got to check out award winning
chef emerald augustine's power air fryer
360. it's an airfry rotisserie toaster
broiler pizza oven more all in one
emerald's airfryer 360 cooks with hot
air not with oil
so that you can cook healthier while you
get
up to 70 percent fewer calories from fat
plus it's much faster than traditional
appliances how do they do it their 360
degree
quick cook turbo heat technology cooks
the food with a whirlwind of superheated
air
that is giving you that great crispy
fried taste
without all of the added fat and
calories also comes with many versatile
accessories
like a crisper tray a pizza rack drip
drip baking pan
i love it i can't get over how terrific
this product is
also especially great for me makes the
cleanup very very easy
me i barely want to scrub a dish okay
clean up super easy emeril's airfryer
360 makes an amazing mother's day gift
right now they have an exclusive offer
just for the michael knowles show if you
go to try emeraldair.com use promo code
knowles you will receive 10
off plus free shipping so head to try
e-m-e-r-i-l-air
dot com and use promo code knowles one
last time triamuralaire.com
and use promo code knowles when aoc
says the justice system is not working
this isn't justice what does she mean
let me ask you something
what is justice we're now told
justice is rehabilitation right that's
what's the point of the justice system
to rehabilitate people i don't know we
could all use a little rehabilitation
couldn't we we all have some bad traits
so why aren't we all in the justice
system
well okay it's not primarily about
rehabilitation but it's about deterrence
yeah
it's good to deter crimes yes i agree
but if you wanted to deter a crime
you could just make an example of
someone who whether or not he committed
the crime or not
right this is what happens in very
authoritarian governments
uh it's not not that oh right
retribution that's that is what the
primary purpose of the justice system is
if you commit a crime you get punished
for that crime
not primarily out of rehabilitation or
primarily out of deterrence
but because you committed the crime and
justice demands it but we don't believe
in justice anymore
even people on the right don't believe
in justice
they have a better conception of it than
people on the left do
but really what this is about is
interest groups
really what this is about is social
engineering
the left is saying regardless of the
facts of the trial don't pay attention
to the facts of the trial
we need chauvin to go to to prison
because
that will create a better society
because that will fight the scourge of
racism yeah it's not about what
chauvinism
forget about george floyd's career of
crime
forget about george floyd yeah he robbed
a woman a pregnant woman at gunpoint
that's not that's beside the point
yeah he was committing a crime at the
very moment he was killed
or just moments prior which was what
prompted his arrest
sure but that's not that's not what this
is about this
is about our leftist vision of society
you got to feel bad for chauvin there
what this means for cops the guy was
doing his job
what what did derek chauvin do that day
he showed up with some other cops
and tried to arrest a criminal who was
committing a crime
it's not even like he went up and he
said you know george not so long ago you
robbed a pregnant woman at gunpoint
that's
so we're going to arrest you now no that
actually would have been unjust right
because these were different situations
but floyd was passing counterfeit bills
and taking a bunch of illegal drugs
and so chauvin does his job tries to
arrest the guy
resists arrest asks to be taken out
maybe chauvin made some mistakes maybe
he did maybe he didn't
i don't know a f a just trial would have
tried to suss that out but regardless
because
basically because derek jovan took on a
risky job
he is now going to go to prison for
murder
but who cares what the witnesses say who
cares what the expert
expert witnesses say in the trial who
cares what the lawyers are saying
this is a political matter and so we
have to turn to the president of the
united states
kamala harris kamala harris and joe
biden both spoke about this last night
kamala spoke first because you know
the president has to speak first so
kamala comes out there
and she says that this
is about george floyd's legacy and we
are all part of that legacy
we are all a part of george
floyd's legacy and our job now
is to honor it and to honor
him thank you
we are not part of george floyd's legacy
i am not part of george floyd's legacy
we should not honor george floyd george
floyd did not live an honorable life
he led a very dishonorable life
he didn't it's not even that he led a
dishonorable life and then he reformed
which plenty of people i think we all
kind of do that
he was committing crimes in his very
last moments
why would we honor that why would we
want to be part of that legacy
i'm not saying if if he really were
murdered i don't think he was murdered
i don't think there's any evidence that
he was murdered i don't think there's
any evidence that his
killing or his death was racially
motivated either
but let's say let's say that
all of that is true and it was this
you know terribly unjust event and
certainly it's tragic death of any man
is tragic
is is that the legacy why is that
what is his legacy george floyd's legacy
is
the stuff he did in his life
he didn't have the sort of life that you
want to write wonderful
autobio biographies about what kamala is
really saying here
is that it's not that we are part of
george floyd's legacy
she's saying we are george floyd's
legacy
that ironically what she's saying is
george george floyd's life didn't matter
isn't that ironic is the whole line is
black lives matter but the point here is
no
george floyd's life did not matter the
things that he actually did
right up until the very last moments of
his life they don't matter
all that matters when we think of george
floyd we should not think of george
floyd
we should think of kamala harris
we should think of leftist politicians
who exploited this guy's death
to radically re-engineer some aspects of
policy
and to destroy credibility in the
justice system
that's the point joe biden
then spoke afterwards is joe i think joe
biden's also in the white house isn't he
i know kamala's running the show over
there but but joe he's
he's still sort of daughters around the
hallways i think he'll kind of
he'll go have lunch then he'll go back
and watch his his episodes in the
afternoon
joe biden had already spoken out joe
biden before the verdict came down he
the president of the united states
pressured the justice system the
judiciary
to give him the verdict that he wanted
he said that he was praying
for the right verdict they're a good
family
and they're calling for peace
and tranquility no matter what that
verdict is
i'm praying the verdict is the right
verdict which is i think it's
overwhelming in my view i wouldn't say
that but see
the jury was sequestered now not hearing
me say that
but so we we just talked to though i
want to know how they were doing just
personally and we
talked about personal things look i
wouldn't say that you know but
hey the jury's sequestered i'm sure
they're not getting any information
about this so
one of the issues in this this trial of
course is that the jury had hadn't been
totally sequestered the whole time you
know
and obviously it doesn't even matter if
they were
this is the biggest story in the world
the left took a local crime story of
criminal gets arrested there's a
question of was their excessive force
used
that that was the whole that's the whole
story this story happens
lots of times every single day but the
left thought this is going to be useful
to push a racial narrative
so we're going to make this not just a
national but an international news story
there's
no way to keep the jury from being
affected by that
and what does joe biden do the the
mostly peaceful fire that blm lit around
the country
he went and poured gasoline on it they
said they we need the right verdict
hey though i'm sure come on man i'm sure
that the
that the jury is not going to be
affected by my statements or maxine
waters statements or
any of the other statements that have
been made for a year give me a break
come on man that's a bunch of malarkey
so joe biden had already set the stage
for this then he comes on after kamala
harris spoke
and he gosh joe biden he couldn't have
been happier with the way the jury
ruled it was a murder
in the full light of day and it ripped
the blinders off
for the whole world to see the systemic
racism the vice president just referred
to
there were systemic races as a stain on
our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
profound fear and trauma the pain the
exhaustion
that black and brown americans
experience every single
day the murder of george floyd
launched a summer a protest we hadn't
seen since the civil rights year in the
60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough enough of this senseless killings
today today's verdict
is a step forward is anything there that
he said true
is any single word that he said true
the peaceful protests the
the unity the the the step forward
what's the step
forward it was an exercise
in the power of the left-wing
establishment
and so he got his will in that the
justice system was overrun
by his political interest group the left
that's true so i guess in a way it's a
step forward for him certainly a step
backward forward and backwards it's a
step
definitely a step in the wrong direction
for the united states
and what it led to i think i don't think
this was an act of the
legal system i think this was a
fundamentally this this verdict
was a fundamentally religious act
and it involved a lot of religious
premises
and it's going to have cultural and
political ramifications
for years and decades to come then we'll
be talking about
the verdict on his show his title the
jury got it wrong
pretty simple you know ben and i don't
always agree on everything but i think
we're
pretty pretty much in agreement on this
and so ben will be giving
much more of a a legal perspective here
i'll be giving the religious perspective
he'll be giving
the the legal perspective here also it's
almost time for another
episode of candace this week's special
guest is dana white president of the
ultimate fighting championship
which is the largest mixed martial arts
organization in the world the show
streams on fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8
pm central
only on dailywire.com you can get 25 off
a new membership with code candace
get the audio podcast canvas on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcasts if you need some candace owns
in your feed
look no further head on over to apple
podcast through spotify and subscribe
today
and be sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear we'll be right
back with a lot more
don't think that what happened yesterday
at the derek chovin trial
was primarily a legal event i don't
think the reading of the verdict was a
legal event i don't think it was based
on a proper reading of the law i don't
think it was based on the evidence
presented in the court
i don't think it was primarily about our
system
or our system of justice that we thought
we had in this country
i think it was primarily a religious
event i think it was
the canonization of saint george floyd
and i think this was about
a a religious ecstasy to triumph
over the evil that had become incarnate
in the person of derek chauvin
the the language that people are using
to talk about this trial they're saying
george floyd sacrificed his life to
justice
he did not he was involved in injustice
for his whole life he was a criminal
i don't look i actually don't think you
should really speak ill of the dead
so i'm not saying george floyd's the
worst person in the world i'm not saying
he never had
a good impulse i'm not saying he never
even tried to pursue that impulse but he
obviously ultimately failed to do it
this is a warning call for a lot of us
there are a lot of people who do a lot
of bad things
who i think are waiting for a
sudden conversion before death well
guess what death can meet us
when we least expect it so you should be
trying to do the right thing you should
be trying to get your
your life and your soul in order before
them regardless of
the if if george floyd had any
intentions to turn his life around
he didn't do it his life was
a an exercise in injustice and yet now
we're being told
he sacrificed his life to justice why
because the facts of his life don't
matter
all that matters about george floyd
according to the left is his skin color
and there is a system of white supremacy
in this country
and and as lebron james says black
people can't walk out of their homes
without being hunted down by racist
whites
that's the narrative totally divorced
from reality
but that is the religious myth
that we are being told by the left
and as a result of this we need to
pursue an inversion of the virtues
in christianity you have the incarnation
of absolute good
that christ himself right christ is the
good he is
god he's the second person of the
trinity he is incarnate into the world
he dies to redeem mankind
in the leftist religion you don't have
the incarnation of absolute good
you have the incarnation of absolute
evil and this is according to
the identity group so you have the
physical representation of absolute evil
which is now you hear this in i guess
white
supremacy the patriarchy writes the
straight white
man who thinks he's a man so he's
cisgendered
right this person and it's always
becoming more narrow into this
absolute distillation of evil that is
the representation of everything that is
wrong in the world
and so regardless of the facts of this
trial if if it can be said to partake of
those issues then you've got to try to
defeat
evil and you'll canonize criminals even
if their death is politically useful for
this purpose that's what's going on
this is a substitute religion
we we still have a liturgical calendar
in this country
okay we have a liturgical calendar we
have whole months
dedicated to leftist views of history
black history month women's history
month
pride month these are it's not even
primarily about black people or women or
homosexuals even
it's about this very particular leftist
view of history
which involves then a liturgical
practice
the new liturgy of of this religion
is the mostly peaceful protest right i
mean that is that is the
religious expression it is the state
church it's why during 2020
the blm riots were protected by the
public health officials who are our high
priests
they said you get to go out you get to
riot you get to protest the george floyd
thing
because and they made up some cockamamie
excuse of how that actually is good for
public health
amid a pandemic to go out and rally by
the thousands but if you go to church if
you go to actual church
that is a violation you will be shut
down the church will be fined
not allowed to do that it's because we
have a state religion in this country
that is
secular progressivism and by the way i
get it man is a naturally religious
being we have religious longings
the leftists who go out in ecstasy to
jump and dance around
and and rob the nike store at their
worst they are engaging in a sort of
community they're engaging in a sort of
liturgy they're engaging in
a perverse inversion of sacraments
they are celebrating their perverse
understanding of virtue
which takes pride the queen of all vices
to to become the highest virtue of all
not even just it's not even just gay
pride it's all sorts of prides fat pride
skinny pride all kinds of pride
that just it inverts all of them it
makes wrath which is a
a deadly sin makes that into a virtue
takes humility which is a virtue it
inverts that it says nope can't no
humility that's awful
patience no we have to be impatient
chastity no we have to be
licentious and promiscuous it just
inverts all of it well okay we're going
to have a religion
everybody's got to serve somebody to
quote bob dylan so that is what is going
on
here but i've got i've got a question
that i think so many people are not
aware
of the religious character of these
rituals
okay fine and maybe we're not going to
reach them
by asking these very heady sorts of
questions
and and point or rather pointing out all
these very kind of
esoteric observations about the way that
the blm people are are rioting and the
way
that we're talking about george floyd
and justice okay
maybe you can ask simple questions
though to get to the heart of this
why is racism wrong first what is racism
right uh racial hatred i guess you would
call is that simple enough
explanation their definition why is
racism wrong
i can say why racism is wrong because
it's an affront against human dignity
because man is made in the image of god
simple that's it that's why it's wrong i
don't think about it too much but you
know that's why
if you were to ask me why it's wrong
that's what i would tell you now let me
ask you
atheist leftist why is racism wrong
if you're on the left especially if
you're a
an atheist materialist there's no such
thing as human dignity
there's no such thing as being made in
the image of god you don't believe in
god
we're all life is just a sort of random
accident isn't it
and we're all just somewhere on the
evolutionary scale
moving toward whatever the logic of
random mutation wants us to move toward
there's no rhyme or reason it's just
this is all just a big
cosmic joke so if that's
true if there is no divine logic to the
universe
then racism is now wrong and they can't
explain
and that's why they are racist by the
way right i mean that's why now the
only the only systemic racism that
exists in the country legal racism is
against white people
and asian people in the form of
affirmative action which disadvantages
whites and asians on the basis of the
race
and gives advantage to black and
hispanic people on the basis of their
race
this is why the left feels no problem
coming out and be
the only the only overt racism that is
permissible in the country right now
is against white people but they'll say
that's not racism and they can't quite
explain what that is because they can't
explain
what racism is and even if they could
they couldn't explain why they're
against it okay first part
second part why is murder wrong why is
murder wrong
let's say derek chovan murdered george
floyd i don't think he did but let's say
he did why is that wrong
if there's no god if there's no image of
god
if there is no human dignity if there is
no
soul if we're all just kind of meat
puppets and it's all just a joke and
that our consciousness is just a
delusion
why is murder wrong we're just meat it
doesn't matter there's no
there's no real substantive difference
there's no
there's no difference in dignity and
moral worth between me and my
tumbler so who cares right
i've never understood this with the the
radical left that denies the whole moral
order
when they harp on the
alleged epidemic of campus rape which is
based on ridiculous statistics that i
knocked down in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now for pre-order who
knows for how long
that will be the case but they will say
you know there's a sexual assault
epidemic right now
harvard is actually more dangerous for
women than downtown
baghdad or something and therefore
we've got to take this very very
seriously
if sex doesn't matter if sex is just you
know we can all just engage in the hook
up culture and we're all just meat
puppets and if it feels good do it
and it's uh look it's nothing it's
nothing and it's just sex who cares come
on
stop making such a big deal you prudes
if sex doesn't matter
then why is sexual assault any worse
than
slapping someone in the face why it's
all
it's if if sex doesn't matter
in some metaphysical way
then why is sexual assault the act is
just the same as any other kind of sex
and if sex doesn't move the needle
really
then even if you call it an assault it's
no different than me punching my buddy
in the shoulder right
now we all know that isn't true but why
why is murder wrong
and then the final question the big
question that we should all be asking
ourselves right now but the left can't
do it
what is justice what is justin there is
an answer to this question
justice is giving to each what it
deserves
putting things in their proper place
acknowledging the objective
moral order and then aligning ourselves
to that
but if you don't believe in that if you
don't think there's an objective moral
order
if you don't think there is an objective
moral arbiter
if you don't believe in any of that
stuff then there is no justice
and there will be no peace and they're
right
and they're if all i mean their premises
are totally off but according to their
premises that's what's going to happen
if this is all just about we human
beings
in our pride trying to be as gods
right the the first lie in the garden of
eden
that created the radical leftist
ideology this according to whitaker
chambers who wrote that excellent book
witness ex-communist
who's one of the people who was
influential in making ronald reagan
turn from liberalism to conservatism
this idea we shall be as gods we shall
totally refashion society
and we'll make up our system of justice
we'll just make it up
it's not the traditional conservative
view is that our justice system is
supposed to reflect
the objective order of justice
the modern liberal view is we'll just
we'll just make it up whatever we want
that's going to be the justice system
because that's what we want
because all that ultimately matters in
politics
is our will our willfulness
and when we're talking about the left
we're not talking about the higher will
the rational will
that that is the mediator between the
lower appetites and the divine will
it isn't that because they don't they
don't believe that that sort of thing
exists
so it's just that lower base appetite
is that justice i don't think so
speaking of lower base desires
give you a great example of this in an
unjust society there's a video just put
up by angela stanton king
who is a right-wing activist this was
apparently the south beach area
lgbt club called palace the blaze
reported on this video where it's at
this drag bar
and they bring little kids up on stage
and have them
pick up the dollar bills that are being
thrown at them during this performance
take a listen
now i'm staying here trying to figure
out why in the hell these people got
these
little bitty ass kids at this drag show
y'all
but it's 11 30 it is 11 40
at night these people have children in a
drag show
look at this [ __ ] now look
look they giving them money yo
little girls now
them picking up money off the floor like
they stripped positions
now so we obviously blurred out the
image we don't want these little girls
faces to be out there uh and we we had
to bleep out the woman's commentary
but i actually wish we didn't have to
bleep out the woman's commentary because
although i i prefer not to use coarse
language in public i prefer not to go
blue
i think this woman is saying exactly
what we're all thinking
i think this woman frank if anything she
was being restrained
could you imagine if you you well i
guess you wouldn't be there right you
wouldn't be at some drag bar in south
beach that would have kids dancing on
the stage but
if you were and you saw that what would
you what must you think
this is such a deeply unjust society
that would permit this sort of thing and
yet according to the logic
of the left that the left is pushing
especially on this gender issue
what's wrong with that well it's fun
it's nice it's open
it's tolerant it's liberating that these
little
little itty bitty girls are being
treated or i don't know if they're girls
or they're boys or dressed like girls i
don't know i don't know i
didn't pay close enough attention to the
video and you shouldn't either let's
just call them girls
what's wrong with them being treated
like strippers and picking up the
stripping is empowering
what's being what's wrong with them
having dollar bills thrown at them
like they're like they're just meat
puppets you know like they're just flesh
we're just flesh that's all we all are
right what's wrong with them being
sexualized we're told
that little children three-year-old kids
ought to be able to make the decision to
castrate themselves
and to mutilate their bodies because
they know their true
sexual essence they have a deep sexual
nature
they are they are sexualized from the
very beginning
and they possess the ability to consent
to these sorts of things
right so we got to get rid of age of
consent laws
we have to if you if you say that a
little kid
can make the informed decision to
mutilate himself and to cut off his
genitals
certainly that little kid can make the
informed decision to dance around for
dollars
that's that's a far less outrageous
sexual sort of decision surely that
little kid can consent
to sexual behavior if you're granting
the premise that the kid can castrate
himself
where is that there doesn't need to be a
coherence
there doesn't need to be a logic here
because with the left the left is
ultimately denying that in favor of
willfulness and interest if i want it
it is good that is ultimately what this
is coming down to and justice
never enters the equation
we are not going to get
more peace the verdict that we got here
is not going to result in peace
in this country to quote the libs
no justice no peace that's that's not a
it's not even just a threat it's a
often a threat when they make it they're
saying if you don't give me what i want
i'm going to burn down the country
but it's also just an observation if you
don't have justice you won't have peace
i'll i'll take this in a very very uh
small example here last night
some lady i don't know some i assume a
lady i don't maybe maybe that's an
unjust uh
description someone tweets at me from an
anonymous twitter account says i just
listened to your show for about three
minutes i have to say you're
i have to say you're one of the most
disgusting people i've ever heard speak
okay i don't i don't mention this
because this is the first mean tweet
i've ever gotten you know i get
i get a lot of those everybody does on
twitter
i bring it up because i want to know
what mania impels somebody
to speak this way to a perfect stranger
what
mania impels you to do that and i
thought this tweet was just perfect as
they say i listen to your show i listen
to you for three minutes you're one of
the most disgusting people i've ever
heard
right i know i know very little about
you i know basically nothing about you
but i
hate you it's basically what this person
is saying
there are two things that could impel
someone to do that
one is just trolling and people do that
on twitter
right they just they just tweet
regardless of what they believe they
just tweet to try to get a reaction out
of you because it's funny because it can
be funny
the other thing is ideology where you
just where you believe that really there
is this embodiment of pure evil
and it's the you know the straight white
conservative man he's the most evil
person in the world and so therefore
you've got to
silence him ostracize him censor him or
worse or physically threaten him
as as is often the case if you're maxine
waters for instance you
you physically you you encourage riots
okay either way
if it's ideology or if it's trolling
even
actually even more so if it's trolling
just a word of caution to people
when we think about justice you are
imperiling your soul if you do this sort
of thing i think there is an idea
that what we do in politics what we do
on tv what we do
in the newspapers or especially what we
do on the internet
doesn't matter it's just pretend the
internet isn't real
it's just make-believe it is real it is
because you really are doing it it's
it's all the things you look at on the
internet the things you say to other
people on the internet the ways you
behave when you think that nobody is
looking
actually do matter because regardless of
what the left wants us to believe about
the nature of justice
there really is an objective moral order
there actually is justice
and we will be accountable someday for
the things that we do
and we want to pretend in our liberal
decadent culture
that we can just sort of push a pause
that we can just sort of
suspend the rules and kind of do
whatever we want because that's my
individual autonomy that's what that's
what i will and my willfulness is all
that's said to matter
but that's not the case there actually
is an objective moral order
and when you turn away from that and
when you do evil things
and when you spend your life involved in
injustice and
crime things don't turn out well
in the here or in the hereafter you
think the anger's over
no justice no peace blm protesters in
new york
ran up to some people i guess mostly
white people who were at a restaurant
screaming to the white people get out of
new york
we don't want you here we don't want you
we don't want you here
we don't
so this guy seems a little bit confused
doesn't he because he's saying
there are a lot of problems with what
he's saying the first is you white man
you white devils we don't want your
taquerias
i say well hold on a second last i
checked taquerias
are they're usually not associated with
like
england right you know they're not
they're kind of a more they're different
isn't that more of a latino kind of
thing or the latinos white i don't i
didn't think that i thought they were
people of color but i guess for the
purposes
of this guy screaming at people dining
in the street
then they're white people obviously this
guy
should be arrested this guy should not
this guy who is disturbing the peace
who is making a big nuisance of himself
should
should not be permitted to do these
sorts of things in society a just
society would
would take care of someone like that
but probably i'm not saying even put him
in prison necessarily he should be in an
institution somewhere okay as well as
the
maniacs following him
but then to say we don't we we who is
the we is that black people is i don't
know we
don't want you white people here in new
york
you know white people have been in new
york for a long time
york i isn't i think that name
comes from a place in england doesn't it
does it before new york was new york it
was new amsterdam amsterdam
there are a lot of white people in
amsterdam too just as there were in new
amsterdam
what is the argument here yeah i guess
his argument is that white people
shouldn't
it's not legitimate for them to be in
new york it's unjust for them to be in
new york what
huh no he's not making any argument
though really he's just saying i
don't want you here my will my base
degraded
degenerate lower will
is insisting that we kick all of you
people out
and that is now effectively our system
of justice in this country
there will not be peace if that is taken
to be our system of justice there can't
be
because there's nothing to rely on
a great consolation in this world is
even though we all suffer injustices i
know it's very fashionable now on the
blm left
to say that only black people ever
suffer injustice and you know white
people they've got it so good
and on the feminist left only women ever
suffer injustice and man man we got it
so good
and only on the intersectional sort of
sexual left only
homosexuals and transsexuals and whoever
people have kind of unusual
sexual behaviors only they have it bad
but straight people oh man they got it
so good
now you know everybody suffers injustice
it's a fallen world and sin and death
pervade the world
and a ballast for us here a great
consolation
is that ultimately there is justice
ultimately there is
the the ultimate arbiter the big judge
in the sky
right and that our justice system here
on earth
is meant to pursue that that very
justice that very same justice which is
eternal even if
if it is imperfectly applied in this
world
if we lose faith in that because we now
have faith in some bizarre
religious understanding some totally
perverse religious understanding of the
world
then there really will not be any peace
aoc absolutely absolutely right on that
minor point
she's probably cheering it on i think
the rest of us people who are looking at
the situation
with a little more sobriety no one can
celebrate what happened yesterday
i'm michael nolis the michael knowles
show see tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy bourie our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
welsh show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show